consiste en tener un balance de 0 entre
las emisiones de carbono que producen
las actividades de los seres humanos
actividades económicas e industriales
con lo que absorben los mares los
bosques y los suelos de estas tres
fuentes son las únicas fuentes en el
mundo que pueden absorber los gases de
efecto invernadero el co2 el carbono y
lo que busca entonces esta neutralidad
cero de carbono es precisamente que las
actividades que generan las industrias o
las áreas económicas en el mundo pues
tengan y puedan ser absorbidas esa misma
cantidad que generan estas actividades
por estas fuentes naturales como los
mares los suelos y la tierra de los
datos en este momento pues se generan
cerca de 11 giga toneladas de carbón
nuestro en el año 2019 se estaban gentes
apenas perdón se están absorbiendo estas
sillas tornan gigatoneladas sin embargo
las actividades industriales de las
hombres en el mundo están generando
cerca de 32 gigatoneladas en el 2019 así
que hay un desbalance y de ahí la
importancia de que estos países se hayan
comprometido para lograr la neutralidad
cero entre los el gas los gases de
efecto invernadero que producen y pues
las fuentes naturales que tanto son
capaces de absorber en este momento no
hay una fuente artificial que logre
absorber la cantidad de gases de efecto
invernadero de co2 de carbono que
producen los hombres y ahí entonces la
importancia de que los países se
comprometan para el 2050 en reducir en
lograr esta neutralidad cero de carbono
para asegurarse entonces que pues estos
gases de infecto de efecto invernadero
no generen que la temperatura del mundo
suba más de 1,5 grados celsius en los
próximos años y se evite entonces pues
la cantidad de catástrofes naturales que
vivimos
en las diferentes temporadas de clima y
en
que se viven en eeuu y que vemos por
ejemplo en inundaciones que vemos en
terremotos o huracanes aquí en eeuu por
ejemplo en este tipo de encuentros suele
haber estos compromisos con fechas pero
son pocos los que realmente se cumplen
que acciones puntuales realizarán las
naciones que buscan la neutralidad en
2050 o en 2060 como es el caso de china
si por ejemplo en el caso de eeuu pues
el vaivén anunció que lanzará un plan o
un plan de financiamiento climático para
el 2020 va a duplicar el presupuesto que
normalmente dirigía a temas climáticos
no solamente a nivel nacional sino a
nivel internacional eso quiere decir que
lo que va a hacer el gobierno de uairén
es decirle a sus agencias de cooperación
internacional que pues el dupliquen y
ayuden aún más a los países que
propongan proyectos que tengan que ver
con la reducción de los gases
invernaderos del carbono así por ejemplo
pues se va a financiar muchos los
proyectos en esta línea en países en
vías de desarrollo también pues eeuu se
comprometió a que para finales del 2030
pues logren reducir a la mitad
precisamente los el carbono co2 que
produce eeuu para acercarse y contribuir
a la meta de
y lograr que la temperatura solo aumente
15 grados celsius y evitar más desastres
naturales además pues dijo el presidente
bailen que cuando habla de
infraestructura perdón cuando habla de
cambio climático está refiriéndose y él
ve la oportunidad en este cambio
climático en empleos es decir para el
cambio climático son más empleos en esto
que tiene que ver y que él ha resaltado
en varios discursos con su plan de
economía verde que está tratando de
meter en su plan de infraestructura un
plan de infraestructura que todavía no
ha sido aprobado por el congreso de eeuu
pero que precisamente este evento y esta
importancia que ha resaltado
yo vaivén en la importancia que
significa para el mundo hacerle frente
al cambio climático pues le sirve de
justificación e serie de argumentos para
avanzar su agenda de infraestructura en
la que gran parte de los proyectos
climáticos están incluidos en esta
agenda y por eso entonces pues el
presidente yo vaya dice que el tema del
cambio climático no solamente es
importante para eeuu sino también para
él
de él